Would you like to have a better memory? What about improved eyesight or sharper hearing? The Apple and Google Play app stores are a testament to people's desire for self-improvement. A search for brain games turns up hundreds of apps that promise to exercise your mind and sharpen your mental skills. But do any of these games deliver on those promises? The field of brain training has attracted controversy as commercial companies heavily market brain training products that aren't necessarily backed by science.
你想要有更好的记忆力吗？改善视力或更敏锐的听力呢？Apple 和 Google Play 应用商店证明了人们对自我提升的渴望。搜索“大脑游戏”，会出现数百款承诺锻炼你的思维并磨炼心理技能的应用程序。但这些游戏中有哪款能兑现这些承诺呢？脑力训练领域一直备受争议，因为商业公司在大力推广不一定有科学依据的脑力训练产品。
Still, many psychological scientists believe that brain training research does hold promise for developing games that can help people, including older adults who want to keep their memory sharp and athletes who want to improve their performance, for example. So what is the state of that research now? Are there games available today that could really give your brain a boost? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
尽管如此，许多心理学家仍然认为，脑力训练研究确实大有可为，有望开发出能够帮助人们的游戏，例如想要保持记忆力敏锐的老年人，以及想要提高表现的运动员。那么，目前这项研究的进展如何呢？当今是否有真正能让你的大脑得到提升的游戏？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学聊天》（Speaking of Psychology），该播客探讨了心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
If you enjoy speaking of psychology, you might want to check out some of the sessions at APA's virtual 2020 convention. You can get unlimited access to hundreds of videos about the latest in psychology for just one low price by registering for access to APA's 2020 virtual convention. Start with some of our selected videos featuring psychology's biggest names,
如果你喜欢《心理学聊天》，你可能会想查看 APA 2020 虚拟大会的一些场次。只需支付一个低廉的价格注册参加 APA 2020 虚拟大会，你就可以无限次观看数百个关于心理学最新进展的视频。从我们精选的由心理学大咖出镜的一些视频开始，
discussing hop topics such as COVID-19, racism, and stigma, or use our on-demand library to explore any psychological topic. Go to convention.APA.org slash podcast. That's convention.a.org slash podcast. Our guest today is Dr. Aaron Sites, a professor of psychology at the University of California, Riverside, and director of the university's Brain Game Center. He and his colleagues research, test, and develop science-based games that aim to improve people's perception and cognitive abilities, including hearing, vision, and memory. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Sites. Hi, happy to be here.
探讨诸如 COVID-19、种族主义和污名化等热门话题，或者使用我们的点播库探索任何心理学主题。请访问 convention.APA.org 斜杠 podcast。即 convention.a.org 斜杠 podcast。我们今天的嘉宾是加州大学河滨分校心理学教授、该大学大脑游戏中心主任阿伦·赛茨（Aaron Sites）博士。他和他的同事们研究、测试和开发基于科学的游戏，旨在提高人们的知觉和认知能力，包括听力、视力和记忆力。欢迎来到《心理学聊天》，赛茨博士。嗨，很高兴来到这里。
It's always good to start with a definition. So what exactly is brain training? You've likened it to physical exercise. Can you explain that analogy? Yeah, the analogy really goes back to some of the science that has led to improvements in physical training. So as in the last century, we learned more about the cardiovascular system and muscle physiology, this led to the ability to train athletes to be stronger, faster, more endurance than previously. And the brain training, there, the analogy is that, well, if we could take what we know about psychology and neuroscience, maybe we could take that knowledge and harness to come up with better ways to train mental fitness. And so that's what we're trying to do. So what's the state of the research right now? Have
从一个定义开始总是好的。那么，到底什么是脑力训练？你曾把它比作体育锻炼。你能解释一下这个类比吗？是的，这个类比实际上可以追溯到一些推动体育训练改进的科学。正如在上个世纪，我们对心血管系统和肌肉生理学有了更多的了解，这使得训练运动员变得更强壮、更快、比以往更有耐力成为可能。对于脑力训练，这里的类比是，如果我们能运用我们对心理学和神经科学的了解，也许我们可以利用这些知识来想出更好的方法来训练心理健康。这就是我们正在尝试做的。那么，目前的研发现状如何？
research has been able to develop brain training games that have been proven to work? So the state of the research is really mixed right now. So there are a lot of studies that are exciting and show demonstration of brain training working. And there's other studies that use similar approaches that fail to find the same effects. And so this has led to somewhat of a crisis in the field. We have some groups that are really enthusiastic about the the positive effects that they have observed. And there's other groups that have been frustrated to the extent that they say that none of this is real.
研究人员是否已经开发出经证明行之有效的脑力训练游戏？所以目前的研发现状确实喜忧参半。因此，有很多令人兴奋的研究，展示了脑力训练发挥作用的证明。还有其他一些使用类似方法的研究未能发现相同的效果。因此，这导致该领域出现了一定程度的危机。我们有一些团队对他们观察到的积极效果感到非常兴奋；而另一些团队则感到沮丧，甚至认为这一切都不是真的。
And that there are not a lot of large-scale studies that really prove that one approach versus another works. But there's enough evidence that people like me are excited to try to do more research so that we can find better demonstrations of which things do work and which things might not. Is the issue funding? Is that why there aren't as many studies as maybe there could be?
而且没有很多大规模的研究真正证明某种方法比另一种方法更有效。但有足够的证据让像我这样的人感到兴奋，试图做更多的研究，以便我们能够更好地证明哪些东西确实有效，哪些东西可能无效。问题出在资金上吗？这就是为什么研究数量没有可能那么多的原因吗？
Funding is part of it in that you need a lot of data to be able to understand what are going to be the outcomes, especially in diverse populations. And that also each group often comes up with their own approach. And so they test their new training study and their population. And so when you have one group that finds a population, positive effect and one group that finds a negative effect, it's often not the case that they've been able to use both trainings against each other to see whether there's true differences or not. And so that if we had funding that was able to support, especially comparison across methods,
资金是其中的一部分原因，因为你需要大量的数据才能了解结果会是什么，尤其是在不同的人群中。而且每个群体通常都会提出自己的方法。因此，他们会在自己的人群中测试他们的新训练研究。因此，当你有一个小组发现人群出现积极效果，而另一个小组发现消极效果时，通常情况并非他们能够将这两种训练相互对比，以了解是否存在真正的差异。因此，如果我们有能够支持特别是跨方法对比的资金，
I think that would be very beneficial to the field. I think that when many people hear the term brain training, they focus on cognitive skills like memory. But you also work on games to improve perceptual skills such as hearing and vision. Can you talk about how training works in those areas? What are the differences? What are the similarities? Yeah, so my research background is in a field called perceptual learning, which has looked at what are the circumstances in which you have, let's say, brain plasticity or behavioral change in perceptual tasks or brain areas that are related to perception. And this field has been really helpful in that we have decades of research showing that certain types of training approaches in vision or hearing can give rise to, changes in pretty much any visual or hearing process that one looks at. However, at the same time, what we've seen in a lot of these studies is a learning tends to be very specific to the details of training. And so what's nice is that there's actually a better experimental basis and
我认为这对该领域将非常大有裨益。我想当许多人听到“脑力训练”这个词时，他们会关注记忆力等认知技能。但你也致力于开发旨在改善听觉和视觉等知觉技能的游戏。你能谈谈训练在这些领域是如何运作的吗？有什么区别？有哪些相似之处？是的，我的研究背景是一个名为“知觉学习”的领域，它研究在什么情况下会发生，比方说，知觉任务中的大脑可塑性或行为改变，或者与知觉相关的大脑区域。这个领域非常有用，因为我们有几十年的研究表明，视觉或听觉中的某些类型的训练方法可以带来几乎人们所关注的任何视觉或听觉过程的变化。然而，与此同时，我们在许多这些研究中看到的是，学习往往非常具体于训练的细节。所以好的一面是，实际上有一个更好的实验基础，
I'd say even theory basis instead of the perceptual learning than we have in training of memory. But the argument is that the neural structures and the mechanisms of learning in the brain are fairly similar across different areas of the neocortex, which we think is playing one of the primary roles in either learning a perceptual task or a memory task. And so what has been one of the main innovations from the ECR Brain Game Center is taking what we know about fields like perceptual learning and trying to apply. them to other areas of brain training or cognitive training, such as memory, to see whether we can take an example of what leads to specific versus generalizable learning and perception. And does that same thing work for specific versus generalized learning and memory? Or other things that we've done is there's a lot of work looking at how attentional and reinforcement processes guide visual perceptual learning. Do these guide changes in the
甚至可以说比记忆训练更好的理论基础来自于知觉学习。但争论的焦点是，新皮层的不同区域中，大脑中的神经结构和学习机制相当相似，我们认为新皮层在学习知觉任务或记忆任务中发挥了主要作用之一。因此，ECR 大脑游戏中心的主要创新之一，就是借鉴我们对知觉学习等领域的了解并尝试应用它们到脑力训练或认知训练的其他领域，例如记忆，看看我们是否可以借鉴知觉中导致特定学习与泛化学习的例子。这同样适用于特定学习与泛化学习以及记忆吗？或者我们做过的其他事情是，有很多工作在研究注意力和强化过程如何指导视觉知觉学习。这些是否也指导着
working memory as well. And so these are a lot of the questions that we ask in our research and that, you know, it's still research. So there's a lot that we need to understand before we'll have answers. Do brain training games show more promise in helping people with deficits like hearing loss, attention deficit, hyperactivity, order, or dementia? Or do they show more promise for people who don't have a deficit but just want to improve their cognitive or perceptual skills? I wish I could give you a definitive answer to the question. It seems to be the case that people who have impairments are some of the best candidates for brain training. At the same time, those are some of the hardest studies to do well. And so that we're kind of, you know, riddled with these small end studies in various patient populations that look encouraging but aren't necessarily very well controlled, don't address the individual differences in terms of which candidates learned versus which ones didn't. And so it looks really exciting, but we don't have as much data as we'd want. We have tons of data in college students, where college students are about
工作记忆的变化。因此，这些都是我们在研究中提出的很多问题，而且，你知道的，这仍然是研究。所以在我们得到答案之前，还有很多东西需要我们去了解。脑力训练游戏在帮助患有听力损失、注意缺陷多动障碍或痴呆症等缺陷的人方面，是否显示出更大的前景？还是说，对于没有缺陷、只是想提高认知或知觉技能的人来说，它们显示出更大的前景？我希望我能给你一个关于这个问题的明确答案。情况似乎是，有损伤的人是脑力训练的一些最佳候选人。与此同时，这些也是最难做好的研究。因此我们有点，你知道的，充斥着各种患者群体中的这些小样本研究，这些研究看起来令人鼓舞，但不一定控制得很好，也没有解决关于哪些候选人学会了而哪些人没有学会的个体差异。因此，它看起来非常令人兴奋，但我们没有我们想要的那么多数据。我们在大学生身上有大量的数据，而大学生在知觉认知能力方面
at their peak in terms of perceptual cognitive abilities. And so it's hard to judge whether these effects are robust. I've done work in athletes that I explained, and with athletes, what's nice, is that they're so good at what they're doing that a tiny improvement in a function they need can lead to a competitive advantage because, you know, when it comes down to it, you look at, you know, things like skiing, you know, one millisecond, you know, or a hundredth of a second might be enough to win versus lose a race. And so that the amount of improvements you need to get that a bit, you know, might be much easier to obtain than seeing a big change in a college student. And does this training persist? I mean, you can do a lot of training in a lab and then send
正处于巅峰时期。因此，很难判断这些效果是否强劲。我在运动员身上做过研究，正如我所解释的那样，对于运动员来说，好的一面是，他们对自己所做的事情非常擅长，以至于他们所需功能的微小改善就能带来竞争优势，因为，你知道的，归根结底，你看看，你知道的，像滑雪这样的事情，一毫秒，你知道的，或者百分之一秒可能就足以赢得或输掉一场比赛。因此，你为了获得优势所需的改善程度，你知道的，可能比看到大学生的巨大变化要容易得多。这种训练能持续吗？我的意思是，你可以在实验室里进行大量的训练，然后把
people out into the world. Have you looked at people, say, six months later to find out, okay, you know, it worked in the lab, but how is it doing in real life six months later? So that's where it's different across studies and that you go back to perceptual learning. There's lots of studies in perceptual learning where people have been brought back six months later, even two years later, and that the learning effects have been retained. So that's really encouraging. It suggests that in certain circumstances, this could be really long-lasting. When you start looking at some of the working memory training studies, well, some of them show that, you know, a month later, a lot of the effects have faded. Others show that there are new positive effects that you could see a month later that didn't exist at the end of the study.
人们送到外面的世界。你有没有对人们进行过调查，比如六个月后，以了解，好吧，你知道，它在实验室里起作用了，但是在现实生活中六个月后情况如何？这就是不同研究之间存在差异的地方，你可以回顾一下知觉学习。在知觉学习中有很多研究，人们在六个月甚至两年后被带回实验室，并且学习效果得到了保留。所以这真的很鼓舞人心。这表明在某些情况下，这可能是非常持久的。当你开始研究一些工作记忆训练研究时，嗯，其中一些表明，你知道，一个月后，很多效果已经消退。另一些则表明，你可能会在一个月后看到在研究结束时并不存在的新积极效果。
And it's something that I want to understand more about. I really wish, once again, that I had the definitive answer of like, this is a the time course of the effect. But one of the ideas of how learning could be long-lasting is especially people who have some form of deficit that they're trying to overcome, that if the training gives rise to the ability to do things they couldn't before, and then now doing things they couldn't do before gives rise to additional learning, then you might expect that there will be, at least in some people, in accumulation after the study ends, where in other people maybe not. And there are so many of these details that are really encouraging from the perspective of the theoretical ideas of how the training could work, but where the data is
这是我想更多了解的事情。我再次真诚地希望我能有一个确切的答案，比如，这就是效果的时间进程。但关于学习如何能够持久的想法之一是，特别是那些试图克服某种形式缺陷的人，如果训练产生了做以前做不到的事情的能力，而现在做以前做不到的事情又产生了额外的学习，那么你可能会预料到，至少在某些人身上，在研究结束后会有所累积，而在其他人身上可能则不会。有太多这样的细节，从训练如何运作的理论思想的角度来看，确实令人鼓舞，但数据却
insufficient to be able to make strong conclusions. A lot of people do Sudoku or crossword puzzles and think that this is going to make their brains sharper, their memory better, that it'll stave off, the effects of aging or even dementia. Is there any data that prove that this is the case? Not really. I mean, there are some studies suggesting that it can be helpful. And generally, with aging, using one's brain is a good thing to maintain its functionality. And so when you have people who really are inactive, either physically or mentally, those are the people where you see the biggest cognitive declines. At the same time, when you see people who do training studies on Suduco or crossword puzzles, they often don't transfer to other tasks.
不足以得出强有力的结论。许多人玩数独或填字游戏，并认为这会让他们的思维更敏捷、记忆力更好，能够抵御衰老甚至痴呆症的影响。有没有任何数据证明情况确实如此？其实并没有。我的意思是，有一些研究表明它可能会有所帮助。一般来说，随着年龄的增长，动脑筋对维持其功能是一件好事。因此，当你遇到那些无论是身体上还是精神上都真正不活跃的人时，这些正是你会看到最大认知衰退的人。与此同时，当你看到那些对数独或填字游戏进行训练研究的人时，他们往往无法将这些技能迁移到其他任务上。
And so one of the piece of advice that I often give when I give a talk talking about the brain training studies. And so people say, like, well, can we just get your apps and then everything will be perfect? Right now, the apps are still research projects. And so the advice that seems to be best is that if you keep on learning, so you kind of move from one task to another task as you mastered it, that seems to be a good approach to stay sharp. And so that Suduco and Crocrow puzzles can be part of that. But once you're really good at Suduco,
因此，自我经常给出的建议之一，当我做关于脑力训练研究的演讲时。人们会说，比如，我们能只买你们的应用程序，然后一切都会完美吗？目前，这些应用程序仍然是研究项目。因此，似乎最好的建议是，如果你不断学习，当你掌握了一个任务后，从一个任务转向另一个任务，这似乎是保持敏捷的好方法。因此，数独和填字游戏可以成为其中的一部分。但是一旦你真的很擅长数独，
doing a lot more Suduco is probably not going to help you keep sharp. That kind of leads me to a question around a gamification part of your work. So how do you translate basic brain training tasks or exercises into games and how important is it to actually turn these things into games to make them more engaging with fancy graphics and sound and scorekeeping? Do those things help people learn better? Yes and no. So one of the things that we learned at the very beginning is that if you just take a task that has some beneficial qualities and you turn it into a game, that game sometimes can make that task harder. And then the feedback that you get, like the scores,
再玩很多数独可能对保持敏捷没有太大帮助。这有点引导我提出了一个关于你的工作中的游戏化部分的问题。那么，你如何将基本的脑力训练任务或练习转化为游戏，将这些东西真正变成游戏以通过精美的图形、声音和记分使它们更具吸引力有多重要？这些东西能帮助人们学得更好吗？可以说是，也可以说不是。我们在最开始学到的一件事是，如果你只是拿一个具有某些有益品质的任务并将其变成游戏，那么该游戏有时会使该任务变得更难。然后你得到的反馈，比如得分，
can potentially distract you from what you want to learn. And in fact, one of the experiences I had with a gamified task where I had a child with ADHD come into the lab, and it was a working memory task where you played it by navigating a spaceship. And the child really liked the fact he could make the ship go fast. And so he just zoomed his ship around, didn't do our task at all.
可能会分散你对想要学习的内容的注意力。事实上，我有过一次与游戏化任务相关的经历，当时我实验室里来了一个患有 ADHD（注意缺陷多动障碍）的小孩，这是一个工作记忆任务，你需要通过驾驶宇宙飞船来玩它。这个孩子非常喜欢他能让飞船开得很快这一点。所以他只是开着他的飞船到处乱窜，根本没有做我们的任务。
And so here, like it's a clear example where the game distracts from the learning opportunity, because the non-gamified version of that task would not allow that escape. And so the thing which is really important about the game is designing it properly so that the elements fit together to achieve a learning outcome, as opposed simply having a motivational structure that makes things fun, but that don't necessarily contribute
所以在这里，就像是一个清晰的例子，游戏分散了学习机会的注意力，因为该任务的非游戏化版本不允许这种逃避。因此，关于游戏非常重要的一点是正确地设计它，以便各个元素组合在一起以实现学习成果，而不是仅仅拥有一个使事情变得有趣但并不一定有助于
to learning. So you want to be entertaining, but not too entertaining? Well, you could be very entertaining as long as you get people to do what you want. So, like, one idea about the game, which I think is really important, is that it's a way to encourage people to engage with a task in the way that you desire. So you could basically set up a system of reinforcement where their successes are given when they do what you want. And their failures are when they do things that you don't want. And so that you basically are kind of channeling them to a stereotyped set of behaviors that are conducive to learning. And so that you can have a really good compelling game that does that, but it's really hard to achieve and that it takes a lot of work. Right now, I understand you're recruiting 30,000 people to take part in an online study to explore whether brain training games can improve people's memory.
学习的激励结构。所以你希望它具有娱乐性，但又不能太具有娱乐性？嗯，只要你能让人做你想让他们做的事，它就可以非常有娱乐性。所以，比如，关于游戏的一个想法，我认为非常重要，那就是它是一种鼓励人们以你想要的方式参与任务的方法。所以你基本上可以建立一个强化系统，当他们做你想要的事情时给予他们成功。当他们做你不希望他们做的事情时，就是他们的失败。因此，你基本上是在引导他们走向一组有利于学习的刻板行为。因此，你可以拥有一个非常精彩引人入胜的游戏来做到这一点，但这很难实现，并且需要付出大量的努力。目前，据我所了解，你正在招募 30,000 人参加一项在线研究，以探讨脑力训练游戏是否能改善人们的记忆力。
Can you talk a little bit about this? What questions are you asking and trying to answer? How does this build on studies that have been done in the past? Yes. Thanks for the opportunity in that the study, actually one correction, it's not to test whether memory training works. Oh, okay. And in fact, the whole design of it is to ask. a slight a different set of questions because I think one of the reasons why the field has not been successful is it's always asking, does this work or does this not work?
你能稍微谈谈这个吗？你正在提出哪些问题并试图回答什么？这建立在过去进行的研究基础之上吗？是的。谢谢你给我这个机会，其实有一个纠正，不是去测试记忆力训练是否有效。哦，好吧。事实上，它的整个设计是为了询问一套
What we're doing is the kind of focus of the NIH grant that is funding this is mediators and moderators of working memory training. And so the moderators are, what are all the subject differences that might contribute to one person to have a pretensity to learn and another person, maybe not. And so can we understand both, you know, from measures of, you know, personality and use of technology and cognitive baselines, you know, who might be good candidates for brain training? And then the mediators are that we have a bunch of different training conditions, all that are working memory trainings that people are assigned to. And we do have some hypotheses of some potentially being better than others. But at the same time, we think that this will break down differently across individuals.
略有不同的问题，因为我认为该领域之所以没有成功的原因之一是它总是在问，这有效还是无效？我们正在做的是资助这项研究的 NIH 基金的重点是工作记忆训练的中介变量和调节变量。因此，调节变量是，可能导致一个人有学习倾向而另一个人可能没有的所有受试者差异是什么？那么，我们能否既从人格测量、技术使用和认知基准的测量中，了解谁可能是脑力训练的好候选人？然后中介变量是，我们有一堆不同的训练条件，所有人都会被分配到这些工作记忆训练中。我们确实有一些假设，认为某些训练可能比其他训练更好。但与此同时，我们认为这在个体之间会有所不同。
And so what we expect is that maybe person A will learn best from training X, but person B might learn best from training Z. And being able to do a study that could look at these differences, now we might observe that it doesn't work for some people. it does work for others, and then also what working means differs across people. So maybe some people, the benefits are only for other working memory tasks, but that might be good because they were not happy with their working memory prior to the study. Where other people, maybe the benefits are transferring farther to things like fluid intelligence,
因此我们所期望的是，也许 A 会从训练 X 中学得最好，但 B 可能会从训练 Z 中学得最好。并且能够做一项可以观察这些差异的研究，现在我们可能会观察到它对某些人不起作用，对其他人起作用，而且“起作用”的含义在不同人之间也不同。所以也许对某些人来说，好处仅适用于其他工作记忆任务，但这可能很好，因为他们在研究之前对自己的工作记忆不满意。而在其他人身上，也许好处会进一步转移到流体智力等方面，
which has been kind of with a very interesting outcomes at working memory training. but being able to understand the interaction between the people who are performing the task, the variety of the task, and the set of possible outcomes now makes it so that we hope to be able to resolve the controversies of the study because instead of does it work or does it not, it's, well, different people get different effects from different tasks. This sounds like a study that perhaps some of our listeners might want to participate, is there a way for people to sign up? Yes.
这可以说是工作记忆训练中非常有趣的结果。但能够理解执行任务的人、任务的多样性以及可能结果集之间的相互作用，现在使得我们希望能够解决关于研究的争议，因为不再是“它有效还是无效”，而是“不同的人从不同的任务中获得不同的效果”。这听起来像是一项我们的一些听众可能想要参与的研究，有什么方法可以让人们报名吗？是的。
So the best way is to go to our web page. So I don't know whether I could share a link to a web portal. I think we can put it in the notes with the podcast. Okay, great. So I could share a link to the web portal in the notes. And also we have an article in Scientific American that helps provide some extra information about the study, which also has a link. Okay, we'll include that so people can find that if they want to take a look. So changing the subject a little bit, brain training games have attracted some controversy over the years,
所以最好的方法是访问我们的网页。所以我不知道是否可以分享网络门户的链接。我想我们可以把它放在播客的备注中。好的，太好了。所以我可以在备注中分享网络门户的链接。而且我们在《科学美国人》（Scientific American）上还有一篇文章，有助于提供一些关于该研究的额外信息，其中也包含一个链接。好的，我们会将其包含在内，以便想要了解的人可以找到它。那么稍微改变一下话题，脑力训练游戏这些年来引起了一些争议，
and I'm sure that we've got listeners who remember news stories from a few years ago about big companies getting into legal trouble for making deceptive claims about what their products could do. So when people, just, you know, for the average person, when they go to the app store and they see a bunch of applications in the brain games area, is it worth giving them a try? What should people be looking for to decide if it's a useful game and that they'll actually get something out of it besides maybe a little bit of entertainment? That's a great question. And the frustrating thing is that it's very difficult for consumer to know which things are going to work for them and which ones won't. That partly is the case that a lot of these products are being sold as entertainment products. And so in response
我相信我们的听众中有人还记得几年前关于大公司因对其产品功能做出虚假宣传而陷入法律麻烦的新闻报道。所以当人们，只是，你知道的，对于普通人来说，当他们去应用商店看到大脑游戏领域的一堆应用程序时，值得尝试一下吗？人们应该寻找什么来决定它是否是一个有用的游戏，除了可能带来一点娱乐之外，他们是否真的能从中得到一些东西？这是一个很好的问题。令人沮丧的是，消费者很难知道哪些东西对他们有用，哪些东西没用。部分原因是其中许多产品都是作为娱乐产品出售的。因此，作为对
to the FTC actions, there's multiple ways that companies can address that. One way is that they could stop making claims, but still sell something through puffery. So kind of like a Red Bull gives you wing statement that kind of makes you think that it's going to work without state it's going to work. Then you have other studies that or companies that have done clinical trials that are good enough for the FTC, but not necessarily convincing to the scientific community. And then you have other companies. So there's a product by Achille Interactive that was just approved by the FDA as a treatment for ADHD that has had a great deal of scrutiny. But the very difficult thing is that it's unclear which of these things that you find will work in any case. And then it's almost impossible to know which ones will work for you.
FTC（联邦贸易委员会）行动的回应，公司可以通过多种方式解决这个问题。一种方式是他们可以停止做出声明，但仍然通过夸大宣传来销售某种东西。有点像“红牛给你翅膀”这种声明，它让你觉得它会起作用，却没有声明它会起作用。然后你有其他研究或公司，他们已经进行了对 FTC 来说足够好、但不一定能说服科学界的临床试验。然后你还有其他公司。因此，有一款由 Akili Interactive 开发的产品刚刚获得 FDA 批准作为 ADHD 的治疗方法，受到了严格的审查。但非常困难的事情是，在任何情况下都不清楚你找到的这些东西中哪一个会起作用。然后几乎不可能知道哪一个对你起作用。
And so the best way I think to proceed is if you think about it as, well, if something doesn't cost too much money, and it could help. Try it out with skepticism and, you know, do it for a little bit. And if it works and you feel that you're able to better attend to things and better remember things, great. If it doesn't realize that you didn't know whether it'd work in the first place, you hopefully didn't spend too much money. And that it's like a lot of other self-help things where, you know, it's if you believe strong claims, then you're going to be really disappointed if they fail. If you realize that this is a place where a lot of good people are trying out techniques that might be promising but are unproven,
因此，我认为最好的前进方式是，如果你这样想，嗯，如果某样东西花不了太多钱，而且它可能会有帮助。抱着怀疑的态度尝试一下，你知道，做一会儿。如果它管用，并且你觉得自己能够更好地集中注意力并更好地记住事情，那就太好了。如果不管用，要知道你一开始并不知道它是否会管用，希望你没有花太多钱。而且这就像许多其他自助事情一样，你知道的，如果你相信强有力的声明，那么如果它们失败了，你将会非常失望。如果你意识到这是一个很多优秀的人都在尝试可能很有前景但未经证实的技术的地方，
then you could basically try them out and see, you know, how does it work for you? What about the games that your center has developed? Are they publicly available? How can people get some of those? So most of them are free downloads on the Apple App Store. and also on Google Play, and that they're available for people to try out. And we're doing work to try to make it so that it's easier to use them.
那么你基本上可以尝试它们，看看，你知道的，它对你来说效果如何？你中心开发的游戏怎么样？它们是公开的吗？人们如何获得其中一些游戏？所以它们大多是 Apple App Store 和 Google Play 上的免费下载，
So some of them have really clear instructions, other than don't, because right now they're research tools. But our whole approach is that we're trying to design games that are going to have potentially better outcomes. And then we're trying to make them available. so that people could try them out and give us feedback. So some of our studies, like the one that we described before, that's when if you enroll, we'll be able to get all your data
并且供人们试用。我们正在做的工作是试图让它们更容易使用。因此，其中一些有非常清晰的说明，有些则没有，因为目前它们是研究工具。但我们的整体方法是，我们试图设计能够带来潜在更好结果的游戏。然后我们试图让它们可用，
and be able to help answer the question. Who are good candidates for working memory training? What are the types of outcomes and trainings that will work best for them? How can we personalize these? And then for other studies, they're earlier stage, and we put our apps out there so people can try them out. but we don't know yet, you know, how it's going to work or who it's going to work for. But if you go to our, you know, the web page is braingamecenter.ucr.edu,
以便人们可以试用并给我们反馈。因此，我们的一些研究，就像我们之前描述的那样，如果你报名参加，我们将能够获取你的所有数据，并能够帮助回答这个问题：谁是工作记忆训练的良好候选人？对他们最有效的成果和训练类型是什么？我们如何个性化这些？对于其他研究，它们还处于早期阶段，我们把我们的应用程序放在那里供人们试用。但我们还不知道，你知道的，它将如何运作，或者它对谁有效。但是如果你去我们的，你知道的，网页是 braingamecenter.ucr.edu，
and you'll have links there for a lot of the games. So that's easier than telling people to go search on the app store or places like that. Just go to the UC Riverside Brain Game Center. Yeah. All right. Well, this has been very interesting. I appreciate your time. and I wish you all good luck with your research.
你会在那里找到许多游戏的链接。所以这比告诉人们去应用商店或其他地方搜索要容易得多。直接去加州大学河滨分校大脑游戏中心就行了。是的。好吧，这非常有趣。我很感谢你的时间，并祝愿你的研究一切顺利。
I think this is really helpful as somebody who's trying to hang on to what little memory she still has left. I'll try a few of your games. So thank you. Thank you. It's a pleasure being here. For those of you who want to learn more about Dr. Sites' work, you can also check out the article on the UC Riverside Brain Game Center that's in the January issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. go to www.apa.org backslash monitor.
我认为这对于一个试图留住她仅存的一点记忆的人来说真的很有帮助。我会尝试你们的一些游戏。所以谢谢你。谢谢你。很高兴来到这里。对于那些想要更多了解赛茨博士的工作的人，你还可以查看 APA 杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）一月号上关于加州大学河滨分校大脑游戏中心的文章。请访问 www.apa.org 斜杠 monitor。
And we will include links to some of the other resources that we've been talking about during the podcast today. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w. Speakingof Psychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们将在今天的播客中附上我们一直在讨论的其他一些资源的链接。你可以在我们的网站 www.SpeakingofPsychology.org 上找到《心理学聊天》的往期节目，或者在你获取播客的任何地方收听。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，请发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学聊天》由李·维纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔达扬（Chris Condayan）。谢谢收听。我是来自美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。